Brynden Tully: Other houses chose dragons,
krakens, and lions for their sigils.
We Tullys took the trout.
That most terrifying of fish, especially when
it leaps out of the water.
I suppose you don't have many options when
you live in the Riverlands.
Could've been worse.
We could have been minnows.
Or wheat (after all, we make a lot of it).
Though a land does not get as fertile as ours
just by water.
The old River Kings, Storm Kings, and the
Kings of the Rock spilled blood here for thousands
of years, squabbling like children over a
new toy.
Until the ironborn came and spanked them with
their axes.
Under Harren the Black, their kingdom stretched
all the way to the Gods Eye, where they built
the largest castle Westeros had ever seen.
Maesters teach that Harren was a fool, but
he had some sense.
If you're going to enslave and torture an
entire people, you best have thick walls to
hide behind.
But the very day the last stone was laid in
Harrenhal, Aegon Targaryen landed in Westeros.
As soon as he saw Aegon's host on the horizon,
my ancestor Edmyn led the mass desertion of
Riverlords to Aegon's side.
I doubt Harren even noticed.
The problem with huge castles is they blind
you to what's outside, both by their size
and the arrogance they inspire.
Not that the ironborn ever lacked for that.
They take pride in their ignorance of every
trapping of civilization.
Though any baker could have told them that
fire turns stone walls into an oven.
And so Harren the Black finally lived up to
his name, and the Riverlords swept the ironborn
back to the sea.
In return for Edmyn's service, House Tully
was made Aegon's new Lord Paramount of the
Trident, and all of the other lords had to
swear us fealty.
But old habits die hard.
The Riverlands are and always have been the
middle child of Westeros, caught up in every
fart from one lord at another.
My ancestors knew that for the Tullys to survive,
alliances must be made.
Our trout has swum up so many rivers over
the centuries and leapt onto so many plates
that it's a wonder half of the realm's sigils
do not have fins by now.
Thus every Tully child is taught "Family,
Duty, Honor," the Tully words.
Euron Greyjoy: Harren of House Hoare inherited
a kingdom that stretched from the Iron Islands
to the Trident.
Too great a kingdom to rule from a castle
as as Pyke.
For forty years, his ironborn plundered the
Riverlands for stone, timber, and slaves to
build a seat worthy of him.
Legend has it that masons laid the final stone
in Harrenhal on the very day that Aegon landed
in Westeros.
Could've been a divine omen.
Could've been the masons wanted to go off
before the dragons got there.
They weren't the only ones.
At Aegon's approach, Harren'sriverlords revolted,
led by House Tully.
I doubt Harren noticed.
Harrenhal could repel an army of a million
men.
No ladder could summit its walls, and ram
could shatter them.
The castle was as impregnable as an old maid's.
Harren shut his gates around himself, his
sons and his ironborn, and waited for Aegon's
army to drain back into the muck.
When Aegon finally saw the monstrous castle,
he asked for parley.
Harren granted it.
Valyria had been the greatest empire the world
had ever seen.
Harren wanted to piss on its ashes.
Viserys Targaryen: (as Aegon) "Yield now,
and you may remain Lord of the Iron Islands.
Yield now, and your sons will live to rule
after you.
You see my army outside your walls.
You see my dragons."
Euron: (as Harren) "What is outside my walls
is of no concern.
Those walls are strong and thick."
Viserys: (as Aegon) "Dragons fly."
Euron: (as Harren) "But stone doesn't burn."
Viserys: (as Aegon) "When the sun sets, your
line shall end."
Euron: Harren spat and returned to his castle.
Once inside, he promised lands, riches, and
Tully's daughters to whoever could bring down
Aegon or his dragon.
As the sun sank below the horizon, all Harren's
men patrolled the battlements, hearing wings
in every gust of wind.
But the moon rose and sank, and no dragon
appeared.
Viserys: While the ironborn were ringing the
battlements, Aegon drove his dragon Balerion
higher and higher in the night sky, so that
even the great castle of Harrenhal looked
like an anthill below them.
Then they plunged straight into the castle,
well inside the guarded walls.
The five towers of Harrenhal reached towards
Aegon like a hand.
Balerion opened his mouth and bathed all the
fingers in flame.
Euron: Harren was right.
Stone doesn't burn, but men do, even when
they're ironborn.
The dragon blasted my ancestors into ash that
choked the survivors when they screamed.
Harren's soldiers leapt from the battlements
and died.
They huddled against the walls and died.
They fled across the yard and died.
Harren and his sons took shelter inside the
castle.
The stone didn't burn, but as Balerion blasted
it with fire, it glowed white-hot.
The world's greatest castle became the world's
greatest oven, baking the last of House Hoare
within it.
Viserys: Outside the castle walls, the towers
of Harrenhal glowed red against the night
and began to twist and melt like five huge
candles, with liquid stone trickling down
their sides like wax.
The next morning, Aegon forged a new Riverlands.
He named the rebel Edmyn Tully as his Lord
Paramount of the Trident and had the other
riverlords swear him fealty as their new liege.
For centuries, House Hoare had terrorized
the Riverlands.
Under House Tully, the Riverlands would, at
last, return to peace and prosperity.
After the castle cooled enough to allow men
inside, Aegon ventured into the ruin he had
made of Harrenhal.
He saw the ashen bodies, the scorched stone,
and the mangled and melted swords of his former
enemies.
To his men's confusion, he ordered these useless
swords collected and sent to his Aegonfort.
Brynden Tully: Men have fought over the Riverlands
since the Dawn Age, but that's to be expected
of things that rest below the Neck.
Doesn't help that the Riverlands are between
everything and everything else.
The Westerlands' gold, the Reach's grain,
the Vale's rock and the North's... snow?
House Mudd once ruled as the Kings of the
Rivers and Hills, but after a thousand years,
their line was exhausted and fell to the Storm
Kings, who fell to the ironborn.
I suppose after years of drowning at sea,
our rivers looked pretty attractive to that
race of pirates.
Never mind that their monstrous castle, Harrenhal,
was too large to staff and garrison.
It turned out the ironborn would not be there
long enough to bother.
Aegon Targaryen landed to our south and, as
had many before him, liked the look of the
Riverlands.
My ancestor Edmyn Tully led the desertion
of Riverlords to his cause and was rewarded
by getting to watch King Harren burn in his
own tower.
Unfortunately, that's not all Edmyn got.
House Tully was named the Lord Paramount of
the Trident, which means we had to keep in
line all those lords who hadn't governed themselves
for thousands of years.
We were now responsible for aiding the Mallisters
at Seagard against the pouting ironborn, whenever
they got cheeky.
For settling Harrenhal on families stupid
enough to think its curse would skip them,
after devouring all previous families.
For keeping the Blackwoods and Brackens from
wiping each other out, and giving us two more
castles to deal with.
For keeping the Freys in their place and out
of others' pockets.
For marrying off our sons and daughters wisely
enough so that we didn't follow House Mudd
into, well, the mud.
Yet under the Targaryens, the Riverlands knew
a peace we hadn't had for centuries, if ever.
But like all good things, sooner or later,
it all goes to . And our had a name.
Aerys Targaryen.
Westeros has had its share of Mad Kings, but
usually, they had the sense not to bully more
than one powerful house at a time.
Aerys soon blundered into a triple alliance.
The North, the Stormlands, and the Vale rose
against him.
But of course, where do you think most of
the blood was spilled?
My brother Hoster guaranteed the answer to
that with the marriage of my niece to Eddard
Stark, the Warden of the North.
At least Hoster didn't send her to Robert.
So, the Riverlands joined the war against
the Mad King; and it was on one of our rivers
that Prince Rhaegar died, sealing the fate
of his dynasty.
Robert was a great soldier and a horrible
king.
He died and another war started.
Again the armies marched, again the Riverlands
burned.
If Westeros is not careful, pretty soon our
people will grow some sense and abandon this
place for a safer realm, like the Dothraki
Sea.
I joke, of course.
The Riverlands are our home and gods help
us, we love it.
Still, as they say, "the king eats and the
hand takes the ." The same is true of the
Riverlands – the Seven Kingdoms piss and
the Riverlands change clothes.